Amsterdam Netherlands famous for its
strict waffle or stroopwafels it's
marijuana
I mean baked goods and it's delicious
slippery raw fish known as herring more
importantly Dutch knew herring yep
that's a headless raw fish this one is
gonna be delicious this is probably the
most famous dish in the Netherlands but
to understand why we must travel to the
dishes origin
welcome to shiva lingam the seaside town
obsessed with the herring illustrated by
this giant herring eating statue I mean
their towns flag even has three herrings
on it oh wait sorry that's a bad example
there we go meat cash he's the owner of
herring house herring is a typical Dutch
fish special TV from here from us we
sell I think two to three hundred
thousands of parents for a year the
herring would be catched
at the end of May begins of June we use
it for the whole year we clean it in the
salt we clean the skin of it we put out
all the balls I think it's the most
interesting fish because it is so very
healthy there are so many vitamins
omega-3 etc in it so you eat herring a
day then the doctor keeps away here is
now mr. herring so fresh so you can
either directly like after cleaning my
perfect way is the way what it did years
before by still and chomp so let's go
back to Amsterdam
here they paring little differently the
Amsterdam way is on a plate chopped in
pieces with some onions and pickles on
the side or in a white sandwich but why
the pickles and onions back in the days
they didn't freeze it so they gets the
herring whole year long and in the
winter times the herring was not so good
anymore so they put some onions and
pickles to kill the taste the dish can't
be found in restaurants only these last
surviving herring stalls scattered
around the dam 50 years ago on every
bridge there was a stand but nowadays
yeah there are seven left here in a mess
so we are the lucky one and they have
won the tourists are scared because I
think it's it's Rob
[Music]
but actually it's it's marinated in
salted water so it's not not that wrong
and they think they're gonna die or
something but that is that's not true
nobody died from herring yeah sure okay
wish me luck
[Music]
right I just want to see that guy eat
that fish one more time unbelievable
click the link below to see more videos
from the tryi like it season